je m'appelle aux médias ce matin je suis
chargé de communication les formateurs
rester et je suis nouvellement élu dans
le canton 18 canton 2 de saint paul
le canton du sein représente depuis
maïdo on passe par guillaume bois rouge
bellemène on a aussi une partie de saint
gilles et au dedans on attend rouge on à
plateau caillou et on à bouillon dans
notre canton donc c'est un canton qui va
depuis les bas jusqu'à les eaux etc
c'est vraiment un canton qui nous tient
à coeur et surtout son mandat de
conseiller départemental parce que c'est
un mandat social et le social c'est
quelque chose qui me tient vraiment à
queue
les actions eux me contant cas jamais
vraiment sur ce mandat c'est pour aider
les malades lorsqu'ils doivent pas sur
un métropole pour subir de grandes
opérations les rapatriements la mise en
place de médecin d'astreinte mais ça
qu'on me consacre déjà beaucoup de temps
à ça à trouver des solutions c'est vrai
que les pas facile c'est pas quelque
chose que l'on pourra trouver la
solution du jour au lendemain mais le
travail vraiment pratiquement tous les
joueurs à trouver des solutions enfin du
moins améliorer ce qui existe déjà et
après nos personnes âgées qui pour nous
il mérite toute notre attention
le débordement pour
ça représente le social à la réunion
donc c'est poids ça c'est comme je
disais à l'instant le social c'est
quelque chose qui nous tient vraiment à
coeur je dis nous parce que je parle
aussi au nom de ma vie d'homme qui nous
tient vraiment à coeur donc c'est pour
ça qu'on a choisi ce mandat la
représenter au mieux les plus démunis en
général et la population